so welcome to a new trailer to the Lion
King live action but not live-action
because it's all CGI movie in a big Lion
King fan you know that that said I do
have thoughts long story short this
trailer goes for the fails I mean it
goes it takes the easy route and it
nails the easy route give us the Lion
King music and the visual imagery and
here we are we're gonna say it now
and that's what this does what the last
trailer dance what this trailer does
bring in that Hans Zimmer music because
it's a great soundtrack which is pretty
much representation or at least allegory
for the entire movie and you see that in
here like there's so many czi 99% of the
scenes in here if not a solid 100 I
could tell you exactly where they go
which on one hand I'm glad they're not
changing a good thing because you know
when remakes do that you're like why did
you do that it was already a perfect
story now you have to make some twists
like what scar was actually his dad like
don't do that just give us the movie
he's give us a story cuz the story's
already great 100% just recreating the
Lion King that's kind of how I'm seeing
this you know people out there like this
doesn't need to be remade it doesn't
need to be made because it's gonna be
the same thing so why remake it I get
the mindset the way I see this I see
this house like an HD remake of a
videogame or re-release rather that's
what it's a rerelease like Final Fantasy
12 is a Final Fantasy game that I
actually really love I guess it was
divisive among fans I didn't know that
because I just thought it was great but
I always loved Final Fantasy 12 for ps2
so I got Final Fantasy 12 zodiac age
which is an HD re-release on ps4 but I
know when I'm playing so D a cage I'm
getting the same game I played back in
the day I'm not getting zodiac Age
expecting a different experience
altogether so you know when watching
this Lion King movie you're getting
generally the same experience you got
from back in the day just a more
photorealistic version of it which
brings me to something that I didn't
think I'd have a problem with but
apparently I do
cuz what am I take away all right first
of all I mean before I get to the
visuals let's get to the voice acting
the voice actors lined up in this movie
are all great we only heard a couple
wonder what your star and I gotta say I
mean I loved she would tell as you for
you know that I'm a huge fan of his but
I liked Jeremy Irons scar better I just
did I just liked the delivery I mean
it's easy to size out the delivery
because it's the same lines
away and never return run away Simba and
never return I know maybe it'll come
across better when I watched the movie
when you kind of get a feel for the
character ya gonna be like oh that's
what they're going for they're going for
kind of a likeable uncle who's not just
outright a creep all right maybe that
makes sense but as I stand right now
Jeremy Irons was more sinister and
villainous perb what a disney villain
would be yes it's just like that better
I actually had a whole monologue in this
video about how the colors look like
muddy [ __ ] in this trailer compared to
the animation to re-watch the trailer
and I was like it's a little unfair I'm
gonna rephrase it here but like
undeniably the colors in this trailer
don't pop as much as I do in the Lion
King animation I think it's just a
byproduct of the fact that animated
colors are more vibrant than real-life
at least the colors of brown lion on
brown rock are more vibrant in an
animation than they are in real life or
at least a CGI movie that's meant to
emulate real life I'm sure the answer
would be like well what do you want
that's how life looks I just open the
movie things don't come across too
monochromatic the lines are kind of
brown the hyenas are kind of Brown scars
brown I mean the animation scar had a
black mane it set him apart and this one
he just looks like a ratty Brown lion as
opposed to Mufasa who looks like I put
together brown lion and looking into it
there are lines with black Mane's but
the mane is black in the back but brown
in the front it looks like that's what
scar has does look like he has black in
his mane but it's behind the brown so
that's what I've noticed is more
realistic route but it does make him
just look like a common lion I will
suspend my disbelief for a better visual
appeal I'm just saying in the animation
the characters had their distinct colors
and they were vibrant colors if you're
like here they're gonna be a little more
dulled down because that's how real life
looks like a brown hyenas on rock
chasing a little brown lions though that
seems pretty business that looks really
sweet that is I said I'm still
interested in seeing this Lion King
movie like is that Lion King fan I want
to see my HD re-release of zodiac Age
it's not really zodiac Age because
that's a metaphor and a comparison for
Lion King yeah this is pretty much all
the fuss I had like I woke up I watch
this trailer I was like these are my
thoughts gonna put them on camera on
film
I guess not on film because it's all
digital whatever now you know and now
you know where I stand
welcome to Wednesday race to the new
lion king trailer have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you wanna see more click right here
to see more Hakuna Matata
you
[Music]